bonsoir aujourd'hui 30 avril nouveau
journal de la rédaction de tv fil 78
l'essentiel de l'actualité locale et
nous parlerons notamment de la rd30 les
travaux progressent à hauteur de plaisir
afin de permettre de désengorger cet axe
régulièrement saturé dans le département
le point sur ce chantier qui ne se
terminera qu'en 2017
nous évoquons aussi les enjeux de
l'intercommunalité pour les communes du
parc naturel de la haute vallée de
chevreuse ce sera le thème d'une réunion
publique qui se tiendra le lundi 4 mai à
saint rémy les chevreuse les
organisateurs seront en plateau
et puis nous verrons comment le parc de
thoiry gère les naissances les soigneurs
nous ont accompagnés à la rencontre et
des bébés élan bisons et ours mardi si
nous parlions de la situation de kesha
ce lycéens sans papiers de saint cyr
l'école qui avait reçu une obligation de
quitter le territoire français à quatre
mois de passer son bac afin de le
soutenir une cérémonie de parrainage
civil a été organisé à l'assemblée
nationale avec le député benoît hamon
sous l'égide du réseau éducation sans
frontières
la préfecture vient aujourd'hui de le
convoquer pour annuler son expulsion une
régularisation complète de sa situation
devrait avoir lieu rapidement
ces images à présent à des salariés de
nexter systems sur le site de satory
près de versailles est des salariés
mobilisés ici comme sur les autres sites
en france du groupe industriel de
l'armement afin de dénoncer les
propositions salariales de la direction
un courrier a été officiellement déposée
au dirigeant en précisant le refus par
l'intersyndicale cgt cfdt cfe cgc et des
augmentations individuelles à hauteur de
0 4 % de la masse salariale les
dividendes touchés par les actionnaires
sont aussi pointés du doigt il ya eu
trois réunions de négociations annuelles
obligatoires comme la loi n'impose son
n'y parle pas que ç'a l'air on parle des
jours de fermeture de l'entreprise on
parle de plein de choses et on parle
salaires et à la troisième réunion de
négociations la direction a enfin
proposé une enveloppe salariale donc à
hauteur de 0 4 % en nous disant que cet
os cette proposition n'était pas
négociable
sachant qu'en plus il met là la
hiérarchie intermédiaire dans une
situation très difficile puisque c'est 0
4% sont à répartir entre les différents
salariés
certains à 0 certains à 0,4 certains 08
donc il ya les très mauvais les mauvais
et les moins bons mais c'est toute façon
pas pape acceptable c1 c'est un manque
de respect total de la direction ouest
ils sont dans le déni du dialogue social
pour l'instant la direction que nous
avons contactées qui ne souhaite pas
faire de communication pour l'instant
transport à présent et les travaux de la
route départementale 30 qui se
poursuivent à hauteur de plaisir un axe
particulièrement saturé qui ne convient
plus aux besoins actuels en matière de
circulation avec l'arrivée à proximité
de nombreux centres commerciaux le point
sur le début de ce chantier qui va durer
près de deux ans avec catherine mulato
sur des images de mathilde lecat perdent
7 août la république droit
oui là elle était déviée oui vraiment ok
elle sera rétablie enfants et la garde
et qui viendra de là bas passera au
chalet ou même au niveau que
qu'aujourd'hui mais six mètres plus bas
c'est une première phase importante qui
vient de débuter dans le chantier de
doublement de la rd 30 à plaisir à
hauteur de la rue jules régné entre la
rn 12 est la première descente du cd 30
la route sera enfoui et un pont créé
pour fluidifier la circulation
mais pas question de construire un
viaduc comme aurait pu s'en inquiéter
les riverains
on va rester au niveau auquel nous
sommes et on va creuser en faire un
dénivelé et le cd 30 le rd 30 passera
dessous cet ouvrage et on peut estimer
que à l'été prochain si on se donne
rendez-vous dans un an
un peu plus d'un an et bien cette phase
de travaux sera achevé cette première
phase de travaux devraient s'achever à
l'été 2016
la deuxième phase concerne le rond-point
du petit saint cloud là encore la rd30
son direction de poissy sera enterré
nous avons enlevé la butte qui était au
centre du giratoire et nous allons
réaliser le futur giratoire à
l'intérieur de l'anneau actuelle donc
pour ne pas bloquer la circulation
essayez les dimensions du giratoire
actuelle était un peu surdimensionné
donc ça nous permet de
faire de réaliser cet ouvrage sans gêner
la situation et nous allons ensuite
décaisser la rd 30 sous le pont passe
pour qu'une partie passe sous l'anneau
du giratoire pour aller en direction de
pau 600 en devoir passer par le l'anneau
du jura pas il en sera alors terminée
travaux de doublement de la rd 30 une
livraison prévue à l'été 2010 est si le
chantier continue de suivre son cours
un chantier à hauteur de 80 millions
d'euros chaque jour 30 mille véhicules
empruntent cet axe stratégique qui relie
la rn 12
au coeur de la ville de plaisir mais
desserte également les centres
commerciaux et permet la liaison vers
poissy
invité du journal ce soir l'union des
amis du parc de la haute vallée de
chevreuse bonsoir catherine joby l'ina
vous en êtes la présidente et bonsoir à
claude carsac vous en êtes le
vice-président votre actualité c'est
cette réunion publique sur
l'intercommunalité à l'espace jean
racine à saint-rémy-lès-chevreuse lundi
4 mai à 20h30 vous allez vous pencher
sur les enjeux pour les communes du parc
de cette réforme territoriale à venir
tout d'abord pourquoi une telle démarche
dans les grandes lignes
est ce que c'est pour exprimer une
inquiétude est ce que vous êtes inquiet
oui le rôle de l'union des amis du parc
c'est quand même de veiller à
l'intégrité du parc naturel de la haute
vallée de chevreuse donc effectivement
cette réforme territoriale pose un
certain nombre de questions et c'est la
raison pour laquelle on organisait un
débat pour que toutes les questions
soient posées soit mis sur la table il y
aura des élus qui sont présents et puis
le public pourra venir poser les
différentes questions on va tout d'abord
par rapport à ce cadre législatif on va
reposer ce cadre législatif 1er janvier
2016 les établissements publics de
coopération intercommunale comme les
agglomérations par exemple comme à saint
quentin en yvelines
on en a déjà parlé sur cette antenne
devront être composées d'au moins deux
cent mille habitants tout ça afin de
permettre notamment une mutualisation
des moyens
concrètement sur votre bassin celui de
la haute vallée de chevreuse ça va
donner quoi en terme de redécoupage
aujourd'hui en principe dans le schéma
département régional pendant du du
préfet la haute vallée de chevreuse et
l'ensemble du territoire du parc n'était
pas directement touché par le schéma
ce qui se passe c'est que en demandant à
toutes les communes de toute
l'ile-de-france de délibéré le préfet un
peu ouvert la boîte de pandore et donc
on a vu un certain nombre de communes et
notamment à partir de l'été 2014
qui enfin de mer qui ont fait des
démarches auprès de la région pour que
leur commune
ce soit rattachée à la communauté
d'agglomération du plateau de saclay ou
de la communauté d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines n'y a pas eu
de l'unité aujourd'hui les divisions
c'est que cette commune regarde un peu
ce qui serait le plus intéressant oui
bien sûr il ya effectivement un grand
débat avec est ce qu on veut rester donc
avec une urbanisation relativement
modérée proche des valeurs du parc
naturel de la haute vallée de chevreuse
ou est-ce qu'on veut rejoindre le grand
pari d'une certaine façon un effectif
considérablement changé considérablement
donc la philosophie du coin bien sûr et
donc on a vu récemment donc qu'il y
avait un certain nombre de d'événements
j'oserais dire de manoeuvre de certains
pour voir un peu comment se placer et on
a été sensible au fait que tout ça se
passe est un peu derrière les citoyens
et qu'il y avait un manque d'information
énormément de gens ont des questions qui
sont des questions basiques sur leur
vivre ensemble
beaucoup de citoyens sont très attachés
à leur mère connaissent leur mère et se
rendent pas forcément compte
qu'aujourd'hui les choses se placent à
une échelle un peu différente et que les
intercommunalités justement sont celles
qui vont dessiner leur cadre de vie pour
les années qui viennent pour avoir de
plus en plus de poids effectivement nam
peut-être aller au delà des départements
puisqu'on le sait les départements sont
plus ou moins à terme condamnés on verra
bien dans les prochaines puces est
encore en discussion il ya toute une
réflexion globale qui est menée
actuellement par le gouvernement dont 4
mai c'est la date qui est choisi pour
cette réunion publique pour informer la
population
c'est pas forcément de les rassurer
c'est de leur apporter des réponses et
vous avez plusieurs intervenants qui
seront présents vous avez réussi à faire
venir même s'ils sont en opposition
quelquefois alors on a réussi
effectivement à mettre autour de la
table les différents protagonistes vous
savez que depuis quelques mois il ya eu
sur pas mal de controverses de démarches
d'élus pour ressortir entre et quitter
leur commune communauté à intégrer une
autre communauté donc et tout ça ça a
créé effectivement un certain nombre de
controverses que qu'on a vu dans la
presse mme et donc on a réussi
effectivement
mettre autour de la table tous les
protagonistes de façon à ce qu'ils
puissent expliquer devant la population
et devant les élus également ben c'est
notamment on va pas citer toute l
heureuse on va petite et toute la russie
a effectivement monsieur jean frédéric
poisson député des yvelines sera présent
président aussi de la communauté
d'agglomération rambouillet territoire
il y aura donc monsieur yves handball
président du parc et un certain nombre
de gens de la communauté de communes de
la haute vallée de chevreuse président
et vice-présidente qui ont des visions
un petit peu différente des choses et
donc est également nous aurons le
fondateur le cofondateur du parquet
dominique julien labruyère qui donc a
beaucoup milité à l'époque vous savez où
toutes ces communes s'étaient regroupés
justement pour ne pas être intégrée à la
ville nouvelle
donc quelque part on est en train de
revivre un petit peu un scénario un peu
identique et publiques donc il pourra
bien évidemment interpellé poser à des
questions tout au long de cette réunion
vont parler des questions qui se posent
concrètement ces questions ah mais c'est
alors c'est ce sont les si vous prenez
par exemple quelque chose qui remue
beaucoup les gens aujourd'hui c'est
toutes les questions de circulation
aujourd'hui c'est bloqué c'est
évidemment lié à l'urbanisation comment
on construit et tout ça évidemment ne
peut pas se régler au niveau d'une
commune c'est forcément des questions
intercommunale et donc il faut
absolument traiter les quais les
problèmes à cette échelle-là et donc
essayer de les traiter de façon
démocratique à 7 à cette échelle qui est
supérieur effectivement comme le disait
catherine tout à l'heure le département
est peut-être en train de disparaître on
va voir la région on va voir les
intercommunalités d'une certaine taille
est évidemment aussi un autre point de
vue c'est comment tout ça va se placer
dans nos zones comme le parc naturel par
rapport au grand paris cette espèce
d'énorme chose qui était en train de se
constituer
comment on va pouvoir vivre ensemble
comment on va pouvoir dialoguer avec et
il faut avoir un poids suffisant pour
dialoguer avec le grand paris qui est en
train de se constituer sans forcément
être intégrés aujourd'hui vous n'avez
pas l'impression aussi que c'est une
volonté de vouloir enfin vous voulez on
peut rester dans un village gaulois
c'est celle que mondiale aux détracteurs
se protéger ce parc naturel alors que
l'urbanisation aussi est nécessaire
parce qu'il faut construire des
logements il faut de la place ça va être
difficile de préserver aussi ce parc
bientôt c'est des questions de fond
aussi si on se place par exemple toutes
nos fédérations par exemple l'ua pnr
font partie de france nature
environnement ile de france et c'est une
question qui est porté à ce niveau là
qui est au niveau de la région ile de
france
est ce que la région ile de france doit
continuer à croître indéfiniment
est ce qu'on doit quand on regarde
aujourd'hui la congestion des transports
la congestion des routes est ce que
véritablement il faut continuer à
croître de cette façon là un cd vraie
question de qui sont plus générale je
dirais que l'intercommunalité et donc
qui se pose alors évidemment le reproche
qui est souvent fait c'est de dire vous
êtes donc une réserve d'indiens bon
n'oublions pas non plus que les espaces
préservés du parc naturel sont un espace
de respiration très apprécié des
franciliens on peut pas non plus le
massacre et on peut parler de votre
collectif juste faire une parenthèse le
but de ce collectif qui regroupe
plusieurs associations c'est de défendre
ce par justement on la part présenté en
introduction oui alors c'est de veiller
effectivement à ce qui conserve son
intégrité mais également de veiller à ce
que la charte du parc vous savez qui est
un projet de territoire qui a quand même
été élaboré par une cinquantaine de
communes qui ont signé quelque chose et
bien que cette charte continue à vivre
et avec avec les acteurs de ce
territoire
on a bien compris l'enjeu si
l'environnement notamment de préserver
ce poumon vert un petit peu en
ile-de-france qui est le parc
et puis il ya d'autres questions qui se
posent aussi sans doute pour les
habitants avec ces changements
d'intercommunalité c'est la question de
la fiscalité et c'est un problème
forcément d'actualité avec les impôts
qui sont augmentés dans chacune des
communes quasiment toutes les communes
sont obligées aujourd'hui avec les
baisses de dotations
c'est les questions que les gens
pourront poser se pose également céder
quatre tout à fait sont des questions
qui se posent d'ailleurs aujourd'hui si
un certain nombre de communes essaye de
sortir de se rapprocher plutôt vers des
grosses agglomérations évidemment à
celles qui sont limitrophes
c'est parce qu'elles craignent d'une
certaine façon que tout l'argent soit
donné pour pour ces grosses
agglomérations de projets donc la
crainte c'est qu'on leur dit mais vous
allez vous êtes vous allez être appauvri
vous avez vous appauvrir si vous restez
tout seul vous ne poserait plus rien et
vous ne pourrez plus avancé donc voilà
donc c'est un petit peu le
l'épée de damoclès ce qu'on sait
qu'aujourd'hui le gouvernement pousse à
ce qui est des agglomérations de plus en
plus grosse et qu elle obligatoirement
qu'elle prenne quelques compétences
obligatoires et que c'est unis c'est en
fonction de ses compétences que l on
rompt des dotations ou des subventions
et c'est donc plus elles prennent de
compétences plus elles sont grosses plus
d'euros de subventions donc c'est vrai
que les petites communes
elles se disent ou si elles se disent si
on reste une petite communauté de
communes qu'est ce qui va nous rester
alors il y aura cette discussion le 4
mai rif les différents élus forcément il
y aura des oppositions va faire savoir y
avoir quelques tensions qui ont qui vont
en débouchés mais au-delà de ça après
puisque pour l'instant vous êtes dans la
discussion dans l'explication
mais après si jamais vous n'êtes pas
entendue finalement si la décision ne
vous plaisent pas on va on va amorcer le
débat
la vraie question c'est que on a vu un
certain nombre de prises de positions
qui sont d'ailleurs plus ou moins en
train d'évoluer 1
mais tant de temps à faire le à nous
faire le coup du ça y est c'est fait
c'est sans consulter les gens nous on
veut animer le débat on veut animer la
discussion de façon à ce que donc se
fasse dans des conditions transparentes
je dirais ça peut avoir un poids parce
que il reste l'expression c'est un sport
et avait peur et si vous n'êtes pas
entendez vous avez déjà réfléchi à
l'après
c'est le lot classique des associations
de continuer à militer sur tout un tas
de questions - et donc alerté d'alerter
la dalle est restée la population et
dont on est on est un acteur et on
essaye donc de de susciter la discussion
pour voir après quelle est la meilleure
solution pour que les choses se fassent
pas par derrière un peu dans des pour
des raisons qui sont pas forcément
toujours je dirais honorable d'une
certaine façon mais les gens peuvent
aussi déjà peut-être poser leurs
questions il ya un site internet en
notre interco point fr tout à fait voilà
lancés il ya trop trottoir voilà les
gens peuvent d'ores et déjà poser des
questions est ce qui aura un compte
rendu qui sera fait aussi pour les gens
qui ne peuvent pas se rendre le 80 on va
on va rebondir bien sûr on va rebondir
on va communiquer c'est comme vous
l'avez dit au début de notre émission là
on a rassemblé les gens d'opinions
différentes pour susciter le débat et on
va voir après où ça va hein c'est
vraiment pour que tout le monde par les
convois quels sont les enjeux et comment
on pourrait donc le faire dans le sens
de l'intérêt général
c'est la première première pierre pardon
donc de votre tout à fait voilà nous
avons aussi invité
directeur général adjoint de l'institut
d'aménagement et d'urbanisme de
l'ile-de-france qui nous fera en premier
une présentation un petit peu du
contexte et des enjeux réunion donc
autour de l'interco en vallée de
chevreuse 4 mai 20h30 espace jean racine
à saint rémy les chevreuse merci à tous
les deux mr second couteau le journal se
poursuit avec la semaine de la mémoire
de l'esclavagé à saint quentin qui va
débuter lundi dans ce cadre sera
officiellement lancé une exposition
autour de la place occupée par la
littérature c'est à la médiathèque jean
rousseau à guyancourt 4 nuls à tolo
diwan la semaine de la mémoire de
l'esclavagé du 4 au 10 mai la
médiathèque jean rousselot a pris les
devants en proposant une exposition très
documentée sur un sujet toujours tabou
c'est un sujet qui est pas évident à
traiter on sait qu'en 2006 quand à
l'idée était lancée
c'est un moment fort ont souffert d'une
évocation christiane taubira qui
expliquait que par cette reconnaissance
c'était aussi la reconnaissance de
l'esclavagé comme crime contre
l'humanité
je crois que la france était un des
premiers pays à le faire
peut-être aussi parce que là elle a
beaucoup occulté dans son histoire donc
je pense que le plus important c'est
surtout en ce moment pour apprendre à
vivre ensemble c'est de réussir à
comprendre quelles sont les raisons
étaient les erreurs de notre passé
l'exposition a été organisée en
partenariat avec culture et tradition
d'outre-mer une association de
guyancourt sur cette exposition allait
monter en plus en mouvement il ya
d'abord effectivement les rafles donc
tout ce qui s'est passé en afrique avant
le commerce triangulaire
après il ya le voyage entre guillemets
entre l'afrique les colonies françaises
après il ya le proto le principe de
résistance avec les neg marrons voilà
les façon de s'organiser pour recouvrer
leur liberté leur liberté la plupart des
documents est propre à la médiathèque
l'objectif est de constituer une
collection évolutive sur ce thème
d'autres moments forts sont prévus mardi
prochain le président de ses théorèmes
mais saaq mac bangou animera une
rencontre débat à 17h30 et le samedi 30
mai à partir de 10h 30
des lectures de textes autour de
l'épisode de rosa park une figure
emblématique de la lutte contre la
ségrégation raciale aux états unis
en 1955 elle avait refusé de céder sa
place dans un bus à un passager blanc
martin luther king avait alors pris sa
défense
loisirs chaque année le zoo de thoiry
voit naître plusieurs animaux dans ses
parcs dans ces enclos à cette année il
ya eu plusieurs zèbres et long du cap et
deux petits oursons les naissances sont
très encadrés par les professionnels de
ce site pour permettre une meilleure
visibilité de tous ces animaux mélanie
poquet et florennes parfait ils ont à
peine trois mois et leur journée ces
oursons d'un rival d'amérique du nord
les passes à s'amuser sous le regard
protecteur de leur maman lui qui est
celui attendri des visiteurs
les oursons avec la maman les oursons
dans l'eau lorsqu'il dort dans les
arbres superbe temps mignon c'est pas
grave mais pas facile va les prendre
mais ils sont vraiment adorables mais
les oursons ne sont pas les seuls
nouveaux nés si les naissances peuvent
arriver chaque mois de l'année pour
certaines espèces les employés de thoiry
essaie de les faire coïncider avec la
bonne saison synonyme de nourriture plus
abondante météo plus clémente et
femelles plus en forme pour les élans du
cas pour faire en sorte effectivement
que les naissances arrive maintenant en
enlevant le mâle reproducteur le mâle
reproducteur on le met l'été valable
mais pendant trois ou quatre mois l'été
on l'enlève ensuite est donc là en
fonction des durées de gestation de
chaque espèce on sait qu'on va avoir les
petits tissu hélas le mal on l'a mis
l'été dernier aux modes de
début juillet les huit petits sont nés
dans le mois d'avril période jugée
idéale par les soigneurs les mois de mai
juin sont tout de même les principaux
moments naturel de naissance de
plusieurs espèces
là on allait donc les goûts bleus on
attend des petits pour normalement le
mois de juin voyez des femelles qui ont
les deux premières devant nous la qui
ont le ventre bien rond bien bien
gonfler les dames vont être quasiment
tous au mois de juin les goûts bleus
vont être quasiment tous au mois de juin
juillet fins générales seuil et des
espèces qui sont assez régler comme ça
les soigneurs ont aussi découvert une
quinzaine d'heures pondu par cette
autruches d'ici quarante jours le zoo de
thoiry devrait envoyer de nouveau faire
part et au retour il n'y a pas que des
naissances chaque année la structure
accueille deux nouveaux pensionnaires à
l'occasion des changes entre parc
français parc européen et vince et bruno
ce sont deux rhinocéros blancs se sont
de nouveau locataire originaire des pays
bas ils rejoignent grassi la femelle des
échanges qui sont notamment un moyen
d'éviter les reproductions
interfamiliales donc de préserver ces
espèces c'est des jeunes mâles donc
forcément ça joue souvent donc ça ça
fait des simulacres de coq de combat fin
lorsqu'on a un sens encore très léger ce
qu'ils sont jeunes force que dans
l'avenir ça risque d'être peut-être un
peu plus vif de temps en temps d'abord
il ya eu la négociation de d'en obtenir
parce qu'il n'y a pas beaucoup de
rhinocéros en captivité il n'y a pas
beaucoup d'animaux disponible et il se
trouve que les deux parcs d'où ils
viennent leur mère à chacun a eu un
nouveau petit donc du coup il était
temps que ces petits parts et ces
jeunes-là parc et donc ça a été une
bonne occasion pour nous l'occasion des
vacances d'avril france miniature
accueillis à la ferme pédagogique rose
pour des rencontres thématiques autour
de la ferme et du printemps hier
mercredi c'était un atelier autour du
pain et la découverte pour le public
également des différentes céréales avant
de passer à la pratique la fabrication
vient autour des céréales parler de
toutes les diversités de céréales et
puis comment on transforme la céréale
ans farid et qu'est ce qu'on fait avec
la farine là on propose de fabriquer du
pain à la ferme rose est une association
une ferme pédagogique et itinérants donc
on se déplace toute l'année dans les
écoles dans les crèches
en maison de retraite dans les
établissements recevant du public
handicapé et on est aussi dans des
grandes fêtes communale demain ce sera
le 1er mai en 2014 les français avaient
dépensé 18,4 millions d'euros pour
l'achat du muguet cette année les
petites clochettes blanches sont bien au
rendez vous elle les professionnels de
la filière ne manque pas l'occasion
d'afficher les pots et votre brun il
faut faire vite car les ventes ne se
font que sur deux jours exemple dans
cette enseigne à montigny le bretonneux
catherine mulato mathilde eu qu'à berne
pour les images
paul est un habitué fidèles clients de
la boutique depuis plus de 20 ans avec
son épouse le premier mec tradition du
muguet oblige il est venu faire le plein
coût de la facture 54 euros 50
c'est une fois par ans norman fait un
peu attention au prix où c'est la
composition mal la composition pu quand
même la crise ce mercredi matin chez
cette fleuriste cela ne désemplit pas
ici 80% des et elles sont consacrées à
la fée clochette entre le muguet en pot
à replanter dans son jardin où les bruns
coupés il y en a pour tous les prix
à partir d'un euro le brun jusqu'à près
de 50 euros pour une composition
dans ce carton les fameux brin arriver
directement ce matin de rungis
son producteur et nantais le muguet en
pot et dui cultivés sous serre et
provient des yvelines l'enjeu est de
taille pour la professionnelle il faut
faire vite et bien
les ventes vont s'échelonner entre ce
mercredi et dimanche
on commet dans notre ligue est à peu
près trois semaines un mois avant le 1er
mai nous récupérons moi je suis allé ce
matin wall chercher mon ami gay parce
que nous n'avons pas de chambres froides
donc on travaille quand miley très frais
et on ne sait pas une semaine avant
comment sera longue et en fonction du
temps donc cette année beaucoup de
chance on a de très beaux mes gars
n'étaient pas bonnes mais on a des bons
muguet c'est un produit pour nous qui
est certainement le produit le plus
difficile à gérer au niveau par rapport
aux autres faites parce que là on est
vraiment tributaires du temps ici la
vente du muguet permet de réaliser 15%
du chiffre d'affaires de l'année c'est
toutefois moins que pour la saint
valentin ou la fête des mères au cours
du marché ce mercredi la botte de 50
brins de muguet s'acheter entre 10 et 20
euros selon la qualité et le lieu de
production l'an passé en france en
raison d'une qualité moyenne de 8,3
millions de pots ont été vendus alors
que les achats de brun est en recul de
19%
et si vous voulez choisir un beau brin
de muguet voici le conseil de la
fleuriste il faut prendre un biais qui
commence à s'ouvrir et on est bien à
l'eau et bien sûr mon eau froide c'est
amir abad problème et il faut savoir que
les particuliers n'ont pas le droit de
vendre le muguet emballés ou mis en
composition les fleuristes se disent
d'ailleurs très attentif à montigny le
bretonneux par exemple la police
municipale intervient surveille les
ventes des particuliers c'est la fin de
cette édition bon week end prolongé je
vous retrouve lundi pour un nouveau
point sur l'actualité est local tout de
suite sur télé file file echo
l'hebdomadaire est dédié à l'économie
préparer présenté par florane parfait
mais